[Music
] embroidery is what I like to do the most
for me it is therapeutic it has helped me
heal in a thousand ways
it has helped me cultivate my patience
[Music]
the most important thing is that it gives me time
with
myself that is me since I started  to embroider
I began to learn to be with myself
my name is gabriela martínez and I am
a Mexican textile designer and artist
I have been embroidering since 2014 I studied
textile design and fashion and in reality
I was kind of lost the whole degree I
did not know what was going to be coming out because
fashion as such because it caused me a lot of
anxiety that it was so ephemeral so
fast that everything takes force the
moment I come across a book
called slow pitch that talks about how to
take the time that things really take to
create a balance  between what we
produce the importance of using our
hands the importance of the trade the
importance of materials the
importance of recycling then that
book helped me a lot to lay the
foundations of  the philosophy that I wanted to carry
was that it was fair to focus on the quality
of the product,
so it made a lot of sense for me to create
something that took a long time to do
and that is something very striking
but something with a lot of history
[Music]
my creative process starts from
nature  I almost always love the entire
ticketing process because it is the
moment when I paint it with
fabric and I see how the
colors react and the combination of textures
after the voltage process I make the
fabric samples to see how the  The
color palette that I chose already behaves
with the threads and the fabric. Normally I do not
mark as they see me. I like to
think that the hand is perfect, so I do
most of the textures that
I make on the fabric by freehand.
that the hand itself creates
the texture and makes the movement,
then pieces are always born that
I didn't even imagine, that's why I like
it to be a slow process also  hand
from scratch gives me a much
larger creative space and opportunity
[Music]
I feel that people are gradually
going to return to crafts more than
anything out of awareness but also
because preserving something with history makes it
much more valuable for  you and I don't talk
so much about money rather as a sentimental value
[Music]